c'est une bataille technique d'avocats
la garde à vue de murielle bolle en 1984
et elle valide c'est au cours de
celle-ci qu'elle avait avoué être avec
bernard laroche le jour du drame avant
de se rétracter quelques jours plus tard
mineure à l'époque elle n'avait pas été
accompagné d'un avocat ni d'un
représentant légal
la loi ne l'imposé pas à l'époque mais
ses avocats estiment que ce n'était pas
conforme à la constitution
nous avons deux principes à valeur
constitutionnelle
la question des garanties qu'il faut
apporter lorsque les mineurs sont
confrontés à l'institution judiciaire et
la question des droits de la défense ce
sont deux principes constitutionnels et
manifestement ces deux principes
constitutionnels n'ont pas été
respectées j'ajouterai que nous sommes
dans une situation qui est complètement
inédite d'une garde à vue qui commence
en 1984 avec une mineure et qui se
poursuit 33 ans plus tard en 2017 avec
une personne majeure pour appuyer leur
requête les avocats de murielle bolle en
avance et que le conseil constitutionnel
s'était prononcé sur cette situation
juridique en 2010 mais seulement pour
les majeurs le parquet général s'est
opposé à cette demande
tout comme les participants si tu oses
là parce que pour saisir le conseil
constitutionnel il faut qu'il ne se soit
pas déjà prononcé
or en réalité le conseil constitutionnel
s'est déjà prononcée pour certains
textes
on ne peut pas faire de rétroactivité et
en tout état de cause le conseil
constitutionnel a déjà statué il n'y a
pas de rétroactivité en la matière
la chambre de l'instruction se décidera
donc le 7 mars prochain de transmettre
ou non cette question à la cour de
cassation
d'ici là la procédure se poursuit et
muriel bolle espère être entendu pour la
première fois sur le fond du dossier par
la juge d'instruction dans les
prochaines semaines ce serait la
première fois depuis sa mise en examen
pour enlèvement et séquestration suivie
de la mort